[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and with poketan making a
big entrance in the latest episode of
the mandalorian
i thought we'd do a deep dive on the
character this video is gonna be a tldr
for the basic backstory of the
mandalorian rs
and our theories and where things could
be going in the future
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the latest entry yet then i
highly recommend that you check out now
if you enjoy this video then please drop
a thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel for breakdowns
like this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into bokeh tan
okay so bogatan dates back all the way
to before the clone wars
i think there's been some continuity
errors with the character
as she looks roughly the same age as
mando
who was a child during the conflict but
whether the show will explain this or
not remains to be seen
who knows maybe someone took some time
out and some carbonite
in order to wait for the whole empire
thing to blow over
anyway beau is played by katie sakov who
not only voiced her in the show
but also returned to play her in the
live-action adaptation
i think she's a fantastic actor and she
fits the role perfectly
so i'm glad she got to play the part
outside of the animation
bowketan cries was born on mandalore and
alongside her sister satin
they helped to shape certain things on
the planet though very little is known
about her early life
what we do know is that her sister
sateen became the duchess of mandalore
and that she made it her mission to lead
them in a certain direction
as we learn from the third episode of
season two there are many traditions and
beliefs within mandalorian culture
and just in that din jaron refuses to
remove his helmet
beau is more than happy to the cultures
on mandalore go far beyond this as well
and sateen wished to create a pacifist
lifestyle for the people of the planet
which would be something similar to what
we saw on naboo
mandalore had been completely decimated
by war and it was headed for a downward
spiral
thus satine believed that she needed to
do something
you see before sateen's intervention
mandalorians were seen as conquerors
and the duchess wanted to drive them
away from this way of life
because of the planet's rich supply of
vescar the locals were able to mine it
and transform it into their armor best
score is able to repel both laser blasts
and lightsabers and this allowed them to
pretty much become the spartans of the
star wars universe
long before beau was born their leader
terra vissler
actually wielded a lightsaber known as
the darksaber
and this became a ceremonial weapon that
we'll discuss in a bit
many mocked the idea that they could
change into pacifists
including bow and this caused a lot of
conflict on the planet
thus instead of embracing this new way
of doing things
beau became a lieutenant of the death
watch and they carried out
several attacks on the planet but were
defeated this led to the death watch
being expelled from mandalore
and thus beau ended up settling on a
snowy planet in the outer rim
known as carlac their leader prie vizsla
started to put the pieces in place to
take back the planet
and this led to the group siding with a
shadowy faction led by darth maul
maul was forming an organization known
as the shadow collective
that was basically well a collective of
shadowy organizations
that would be used by the sith in order
to get him power
he promised the death watch that he
would help them take back the planet
but beau had her doubts the character
just didn't trust the sith or the jedi
and viewed them as people who would
fight for their own agenda
rather than hers during this time beau
also met ahsoka
and though they were enemies at first
the pair would become great allies
during the events of the clone wars
now after joining with maul the shadow
collective launched an assault on
mandalore
and because the teen didn't really
believe in fighting all that much
they were quickly overthrown vizzler
took charge of the planet
but there was a power struggle and maul
actually challenged him for the throne
the sect believed that only the
strongest should rule and thus they
fought one another for the position
maul managed to best him and took the
throne and darksaber for himself
this is where beau really forged her own
destiny and after watching the leader
she'd served
get decapitated in front of her she and
other loyalists decided that they
wouldn't recognize malt's rule
beau believed that no outsiders should
be on the throne and thus she enacted
her own uprising
beau helped to free sateen from prison
but mueller murdered her
in front of obi-wan you see obi-wan kind
of had a thing for sateen growing up
and he actually admitted that he would
have left the jedi order if she'd asked
him to
this was a real kick in the teeth for
the character and also
kickstarted the great power struggle of
mandalore
this still doesn't even really feel like
it's been settled after the fall of the
empire
and it's one of the main driving forces
in bold's life now beau ended up
becoming allies with ahsoka
in a bid to take back mandalore ahsoka
had left the jedi order
but she was still extremely skilled in
the ways of the force
and more than capable as a jedi
mandalore once more descended into a
civil war
but belle managed to take back the
planet due to help from clone troopers
and ahsoka
beau was appointed the region of
mandalore but that didn't mean it was
over
after the events of order 66 emperor
palpatine told her that the planet would
have to join the galactic empire
but beau refused to do this thus she was
expelled
and mandalore was taken over by
palpatine and clan saxon
mandalore was further thrown into
conflict and another civil war arose on
the planet
with the clan wren of crownist rising up
against the empire
during this time beau met countess ursa
and sabine wren
who became big characters in star wars
law now in case you missed our video in
which we discussed how we thought sasha
banks was playing sabine
here's a quick catch up sabine was
basically a member of the imperial
academy
who thought that she was aiding the
empire in bringing peace to her planet
however after she realized that her
weapons were actually being used as a
way to oppress the people
she turned against the imperials sabine
fled and joined a rebel group known as
the specters
and we follow her throughout the
animated series rebels
now sabine actually discovered the dark
saber on dathomir
aka darth maul's home planet and the
character
even wielded it herself like many of the
mandalorians
sabine believed that whoever held it
would be the true ruler of the planet
she ended up returning to mandalore and
managed to defeat the imperial forces
sabine gifted by the darksaber and she
finally got to be
the leader of the mandalorians and
whilst this did give the character a
happy ending
for a bit moff gideon had to ruin all
that
and we did learn in the mandalorian that
he and his forces had seized the planet
this was something known as the great
perch in which the empire supplanted the
mandalorians once more
gideon had taken the darksaber for
himself and thus the fate of beau had
been up in the air for a long time
many people believed that beau would not
part with the blade and that she may
have lost it along with her life in
combat
now we do know that gideon and his
forces likely swarmed the planet
and simply forced her to retreat we do
know that mandalorians are spread thinly
throughout the galaxy
and many including dingiorin believe
that after all the conflicts
that the planet has become inhospitable
however
beau has stated that this is untrue and
that this misinformation has been pushed
by the imperials
to divide the mandalorians up as much as
possible
thus since then beau has been biting her
time
and on trask she has slowly started to
enact a plan to take back
the planet with her team we watch as she
storms an imperial ship
in order to learn the location of moff
gideon i think that going forward she
will actually help mando defeat him
in episode 2 of season 2 we saw that
some bounty hunters
were still after the child and these
were likely sent by the villain
who will still want the creature for
himself season 1
very much had this idea of mando making
allies with people
and i think that he and bo will work
together in order to stop them off once
and for all
you have to know that at this point mano
doesn't actually know that the moff is
alive
and as he was never brought up during
the conversation with beau
it is likely that the two don't realize
they're after the same thing
after mando meets with ahsoka it is
possible that he will learn the identity
of the person wielding the darksaber
as he doesn't really know at this point
and this could then make him return to
beau
by the time he's gone through all this
we will be further into the series
and beau will have had time to gather
more armaments so who knows
we might actually see mando and co team
up to take back mandalore
it's the character's destiny to be the
ruler of the planet and i really hope
that she finally accomplishes her goal
and get some more closure
on it anyway that should be everything
you need to know
about bow and obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on her and where you think
things could be going in the future
make sure you comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up
we've also dropped a big episode on the
ins and outs of the latest entry
so if you want to come check out some
cool little easter eggs in there then
definitely go watch it after this
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the marvel phase two box set
and all you have to do to be with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of november so make sure you
get involved
going to support the channel and get to
see content early and please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come chapters on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you been the best i've been paul and
i'll see you next time take care
peace
you